just for you get started with this video
you've probably seen recently on this
channel that there are a couple of new
people hosting it along with me this is
a sort of transitional period as I am
slowly and sadly leaving visual politic
to pursue other projects as many of you
know I have other channels and I do
other things and you know a career is a
fluid thing and despite what
conspiracies you might read in the
comments etc I'm fired
there's no animosity this is a very
happy departure from everyone here at
visual politic I'm just moving on to
other things I'm excited to have worked
on this project with everyone involved
and I really think you guys will love
Josh and grants who are taking over the
hosting duties from me and with that
said let's crack on
[Applause]
[Music]
the pandemic of the new corona virus is
not only a public health crisis it's
also an economic crisis and behind the
numbers the graphs and statistics of the
real tragedies tragedies like this
Nissan closes its Barcelona plant with
3,000 workers affected the economists
and we're not only talking about the
3,000 people who lost their jobs a car
factory generates thousands of indirect
jobs to around the Nissan Factory there
were a lot of auxilary companies
companies that manufactured engine
components brake tubes exhaust pipes and
a lot of other things in total we're
talking about more than 25,000 people in
Barcelona who will almost certainly lose
their jobs we're talking about a really
dramatic situation and it may not be the
last car factory to close but I'm sure
none of this is going to surprise you no
one disputes that the corona virus has
brought us all into a global recession
throughout this year 2020 almost all
countries will experience some form of
economic crisis
the question is are we talking about one
more crisis or are we talking about the
zombie apocalypse and as always the
answer is not yes or a no but rather and
it depends for example in the Czech
Republic unemployment has barely risen
to 5% of course they are also in crisis
but it's a much smaller crisis however
there are other economic sectors and
above all other countries where we can
talk about a real zombie apocalypse or
disaster you know the economic version
of The Walking Dead and one of those
countries is Spain Brussels expects GDP
to fall by 9 point 4 percent and
unemployment to rise to 18 point nine
percent in Spain in 2020 expansion
exactly everything points to Spain in
Italy being the country's most damaged
by this crisis on one hands they are two
of the countries most affected by the
health crisis at the time of making this
video Spain has the highest mortality
rate in the world passed only by Belgium
and this is due to a series of
catastrophic misfortunes that we
explained in another video
but that's not the worst of it both
Spain and Italy are still feeling the
effects of the 2008 financial crisis a
crisis from which they have not
recovered to give you an idea in 2019
Spain at almost 15 percent unemployment
in some areas it even exceeded 20
percent there are a whole generation of
Spaniards who've neither study nor work
who are called the ninnies new trabajar
new studio in Spanish we are talking
about people who are 30 years old and
still living with their parents because
they haven't found a steady job it's a
real national drama and this was the pre
pandemic outlook when all of Europe was
expanding imagine what might happen next
given the backdrop of the pandemic and I
know what a lot of you are going to be
thinking but why is there a crisis I
mean ok the months the economy has been
stalled for months almost all companies
have stopped production but when we get
back to work everything should go back
to normal right well yes in many cases
that's what's going to happen as an
example Google stocks have already
recovered on the stock exchange however
this doesn't mean Google doesn't have
problems but it does show us that there
are sectors that can recover now imagine
a neighborhood bar Kassem and no lo they
sell traditional Spanish cuisine and
beer at 2 euros of serving Casa Manolo
has two workers Manolo and a cook named
Carmen this bar generates a profit of
about 4000 euros per month just enough
than the no-load to make ends needs and
pay common salary if it's profit common
salary would have been taken out so it's
not really profit but two months without
income can result in closure that means
Manolo sells the bar and common has no
work well there are thousands of cases
like this in Spain and everywhere else
but we're not just talking about bars
there are also large companies that were
not prepared for quarantine companies
like this
[Applause]
earth says coronavirus decimated revenue
leading to bankruptcy
still all of this is a global trend so
the question is why is Spain having more
problems than other countries what are
the hurdles that this country faces that
Germany or the United States don't have
more importantly is there a chance of
sidestepping those hurdles well today
we're going to answer these questions
but first let us take a look back at the
history
[Music]
the perfect storm in every crisis there
are winners and there are losers
companies such as Amazon and Netflix
have been reinforced because of the
coronavirus which begs the question who
are the biggest victims of the pandemic
and I think you can guess the answer
that's Airlines this will be the last
sector to open after quarantine and many
are already going broke Avianca one of
Latin America's largest airlines files
for bankruptcy CNN so which sectors are
best prepared to survive the crisis
apart from internet-based companies we
can talk about industry many factories
have been able to adapt a quarantine for
example in order to make this video we
were talking to an Atlas Copco manager
in the Czech Republic
Atlas Copco is a multinational company
that manufactures air compressors vacuum
machines and in general industrial
machinery every summer they take
advantage of the holidays to carry out
maintenance ping machines checks and fix
anything you know the usual stuff well
this year instead of waiting until
summer they did it during quarantine the
same is happening with many other
companies however within the industry
sector there is one subgroup that is
having a particularly bad time and we're
not talking about a small player we're
talking about this giant
auto industry hit from coronavirus could
be even bigger than the latest forecast
if you've been following visual politic
for a while you'll already know this
because we have told you several times
the major car manufacturers have been
struggling for years to give you an idea
before the pandemic pitch which is a
debt rating agency considered Renaud's
debt to be a junk box well if the
Renault group was already in a bad
situation the pandemic has just put them
up on the brink of bankruptcy
[Music]
as an example in 2018 Renaud's shares
were trading at about ninety eight euros
each by February 2020 that is before the
crisis they were already down to around
30 euros a month later they were around
15 euros this is an upheaval it has
forced the company to sit down and take
drastic actions so far they've already
said that they're going to fire 15,000
people around the world on the first
three thousands of the misfortune of
being based in Barcelona this encloses
its Barcelona Factory and its 3,000
employees are out of work during the
coronavirus crisis and the truth is
they're probably not going to be the
only ones this son has two other plants
in Spain one in Evita and one in
Santander Renault has three other plants
validated palencia and Seville it may
come as a surprise but Spain is the
second largest car producer in Europe
second only to Germany Spain has one of
the great leaders in the automotive
industry and that just happens to be one
of the worst off sectors right now
[Music]
so now let's recap two of the sector's
most affected by coronavirus tourism and
the automotive industry tourism amounts
for 11 percent of Spain's GDP automotive
eight point seven percent in total we're
talking about almost twenty percent of
Spain's GDP that is one-fifth of the
economy is seriously affected by the
coronavirus so how about the other 80
percent well the truth is it's not
looking too good either let's go back to
the example of Casa Manolo the typical
neighborhood bar that has one or two
workers I mean it's what we call a micro
enterprise the kind of business that's
most exposed to their pandemic well
check out this chart take into account
that in Germany 82 percent of businesses
what we call micro enterprises in Spain
and Italy that number goes up to 95
percent and well what does all of this
mean we told you in previous videos
Germany is a very strong economy it
thinks in part having many medium-sized
enterprises for example Desna is a
german company with over 200 workers
they are the world leaders in making
machines to make shoe soles I know this
is very specific niche but Desmet is
number one in it they sell their
machines everywhere China the United
States Spain everywhere that shoe soles
and manufactured is likely to be a
decimal machine they probably have
problems with the crisis in this company
too but they have enough savings and are
competitive enough to be able to endure
a bad year without having to close
however a micro enterprise like Casa
Manolo is unlikely to be that prepared
give you an idea of the average company
in Germany as 7.6 employees in Spain its
3.9
in other words in Spain there are large
companies on one side and micro
companies on the other there's barely
any middle ground at all that means that
Spain is much more exposed to any
economic crisis and I know what a lot of
you are gonna be thinking the time has
finally come when states are going to
have to rescue their economies
really that is before Casa Manolo closes
the Spanish state arrives and gives it a
grant or a loan so that it can cover all
of the shortfalls caused by the pandemic
and well if you're thinking that you're
right I think even the most liberal will
agree that at times like this the states
help is needed again the problem is not
that all states are the same and the
Spanish state is not exactly at a high
point we mentioned a moment ago about
the zombie apocalypse well now we need
to talk about the Walking Dead
The Walking Dead whether they're
left-wing or right-wing every government
in the world helps their businesses in
total European countries have already
spent more than 2 trillion euros to
rescue their economies and yes we said
trillion that is a - followed by 12
zeros
almost half of that 2 trillion euros are
for Germany for example - remember me
saying about how many airlines are
closing down while Germany is already
doing everything again to avoid this at
least on its own territory
Germany reaches EU deal or nine point
nine billion loot Hansa be licked
and yes Germany has had to ask Europe
for mission because European law
prohibits governments from bailing out
their own companies this is violation of
free competition however we are talking
about an extraordinary situation and at
a time like this Brussels is allowing
things that would have been totally
illegal at any other time but the
question is who pays for all of this
does Germany of so much money that it is
able to rescue all of its companies and
the truth is well no Germany like Spain
France or Italy will have to borrow that
money we're talking about debt bonds
that are issued to market and you'll say
ok well where's the problem with that
why can Germany go into debt and Spain
cannot well this is where another of
Spain's great problems comes to light
John public debt is equivalent to less
than 60% of its GDP in Spain that number
is already above 95% in Italy we're
talking about more than a hundred and
thirty-four percent
now imagine you're an investor actually
a lot of you probably are so ask
yourself this question which dead bond
would you buy first the German which can
be paid back at any time or the Spanish
although you have it all of this
explains the following coronavirus the
president of the EU Commission von der
Leyen calls a 750 billion euro recovery
fund Europe's moment we talked about
this in another video a month ago no one
doubts that Europe has to help Spain in
Italy the question is how's that help
coming the first debate centered around
corona bonds in short the northern
countries of the eurozone wanted to
lends money to the countries of the
south on the condition of political
supervision the South wanted free
unconditional money now the debate is
about whether your upside has to be
loans or subsidies and finally the
European Commission has reached a middle
ground 500 billion euros in grants and
public expenditure 250 billion euros in
very low interest loans their money will
come out of debt bonds that the European
Union will bring to the international
market it's very likely that many of
these bonds will end up being bought by
the European Central Bank and the
question the real question is is this
gonna be enough we're all simply sending
money to Spain be enough to make the
Spanish economy recover well we're going
to take a look right now what will
happen
more excel and less powerpoint money is
important but it doesn't work miracles
the best example of this is the high
speed train in recent decades Europe has
spent more than 11 billion euros for
Spain to have high-speed rail
today Spaniards have the third-largest
high-speed rail network in the world
behind China in Japan the question is
has it created advantages and the answer
is well not really we already explained
it in other videos from a purely
economic point of view the Spanish
high-speed train the so called are they
is a gigantic hole in national accounts
and does barely serve to generate
economic growth it cannot be used to
transport goods only passengers and from
a social point of view it is not very
user-friendly either the train ticket in
Spain is between 40 percent and 100
percent more expensive than an
equivalent journey in Germany or the
Czech Republic and the same goes for
ghost airports Spain has a few airports
that hardly have flights that cost a
real fortune we are talking about
billions of euros that have been spent
for purely electoral political or
ideological reasons
at this point in time what Spain needs
is more excel and less powerpoint and
the question is at what extent is Spain
willing to leave political quarrels
behind and focus on pure economic
management's well what can I tell you
news stories like this a pretty
disappointing
dismissal of civil guard chief prompts
political dispute over rule of law
Spain's government has plunged into a
dispute involving allegations of server
ting the rule of law and undermining
democracy and a faceoff with one of the
country's most formidable institutions
and to this the fact that Spain
currently has a coalition government a
coalition between the Socialists
center-left and pas de mas which is a
far left party and if you thought
left-wing parties always understood each
other well you're quite wrong there is
growing tension between what might be
called the moderate wing of the
government and the more radical wing and
if there are tensions within the
government itself you can already
imagine what is happening in the
opposition parties the political
environment is really really polarized
and this is worrying because Spain will
have no choice but to cut costs and take
unpopular measures
[Music]
many of these measures will need the
support of the opposition at least more
moderate members however judge for
yourselves what you're gonna see now is
a scene from Parliament for those
unfamiliar with Spanish politics the one
with the ponytail is the vice president
of the government and the one with the
beard is a member of the far-right party
take a look and tell me how unanimous
decisions on essential measures can be
reached in this environment
Creason Espinoza de los Montero que
ustedes les gustaría la Ronn golpe de
estado pero que nos a Trevin a silicon
terrorist theory of solution area so now
the questions are over to you do you
think that Europe can force spanish
politicians to be more responsible is it
possible for European aid to help
prevent the zombie apocalypse and so
makes the crisis more bearable you can
leave your answer in the comments
section below and as always if you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button don't forget to subscribe
thank you for watching